well let's now speak to Abdullah
al-arian who's associate professor of
history at Georgetown University here in
Qatar and author of football in the
Middle East State society and the
Beautiful game Abdullah thank you very
much for being with us on Al Jazeera
such a life such a legacy how in your
view did Pele transform football
well I mean I think if we if we go back
to the era in which he emerged I mean in
the 1950s you didn't really have a
global uh athlete someone who kind of uh
you know embodied the kinds of qualities
that we tend to associate today with
some of the truly Global athletes and so
in some ways he was really the first
maybe alongside only someone like
Muhammad Ali someone who really captured
the imagination of populations across
the globe
um you know someone who who's who kind
of existed in a state of Mythology in a
way given the kinds of stories that
circulated around his performances long
before televisions were present in every
home and people would kind of have to
recap uh you know all of his
achievements winning a World Cup at such
a young age and then doing it again 12
years later having three of those
trophies something that has never been
equal let alone surpassed and unlikely
based on kind of what we've seen even
just in the most recent World Cup seeing
France kind of failed to even get it a
second time in a row so there are a
number of achievements here that I think
are are truly things that we'll live on
yeah and all the skills you know that we
see from our favorite players today
whether it's Neymar Messi Ronaldo Pele
did first didn't he he could create
emotions through football unlike any
other place
yeah I mean his his playstyle I think is
the thing that he's most known for the
fact that he kind of revolutionized the
game given the way that he approached it
with uh the kind of improvisation The
Joy
um you know the the kind of you know
breaking boundaries in a way going
outside the normal kind of rules or
um you know the kind of structures in
which the game had been played obviously
it was very much a kind of a European uh
invention a game that was dominated very
much by European side that all of a
sudden kind of Brazil emerges as this
Major Force largely because teams simply
had no answer for the style of play
um that the Brazilian team brought but
really personified in Pele as kind of
being the the player who kind of
approached it with such uh such Joy
spontaneity improvisation and we see it
in all of the clips that have since
circulated and the ones that of course
the more that that Global audiences then
had access to be able to see him not
just through television but eventually
through the kind of Tours that Santos
took to be able to travel to different
parts of the world yeah he did travel to
different parts to the world to Africa
and so on and and he United Abdullah he
United Brazil a country that's been torn
apart as we've seen recently by politics
uh he encapsulated really the powerful
Global unifying Spirit of football will
they ever be another football player
that did what he did
it's it's hard to to imagine that there
could be only because I think the
circumstances the context in which he
emerged is so so different now right now
we live in a much more uh you know media
dominated environment in which people
are basically their brands I think we
even saw that happen with parlay toward
the end of his life in which they become
much more commodified and so it's much
more difficult to kind of Imagine The
emergence of kind of you know figures
that that emerge in this kind of
spontaneous space where they can really
just personify the spirit of what they
embody on the field given the kinds of
adversity that he overcame when we know
about the background in terms of the
impoverishment that so many segments of
Brazilian Society encountered and then
of course the racism the anti-black
racism that existed and the lead up to
the 1958 World Cup that that kind of
allowed him to surpass many of those
kinds of challenges both within Brazil
and then of course globally you talked
about there about the evolution of
football what did he make of it what you
know the fact that football has become
so commercialized the business side of
it making it today one of the most
powerful Industries in the world what
did he make of that
well I mean I think if we look at his
later statements and and his kind of
encounters with some of today's uh
modern Superstars I mean there seemed to
be a kind of embracing of the power that
football brings the idea that it has to
capture imagination the idea that these
Superstars have a platform far bigger
even than the one that he may have had
during his career and so he was much
more welcoming and embracing of stars
like Neymar and Messi and others who of
course have a much more broader reach in
a global reach in the way that they are
without necessarily having the kind of
criticism perhaps of the commodification
of the sport in a way but hoping that at
least that this platform could be used
to kind of encourage
um you know a certain kind of coming
together that we see in things like the
World Cup most recently and other kinds
of events Abdullah thank you so much for
talking to us about this about pele's
Legacy El Abdullah Aryan joining us
there from Doha